We now continue our discussion
of infinite series.
Sometimes we have to deal with
series where the terms being
added are indexed by multiple
indices, as in
this example here.
We're given numbers, aij,
and i ranges over all
the positive integers.
j also ranges over all the
positive integers.
So what does this
sum represent?
We can think of it as follows.
We have here a two-dimensional
grid that corresponds to all
the pairs (i,j).
And in essence, each one of
those points corresponds to
one of the terms that
we want to add.
So we can sum the different
terms in some arbitrary order.
Let's say we start from here.
Take that term, add this term,
then add this term here, then
add this term, then the next
term, next term, and so on.
And we can keep going that
way, adding the different
terms according to
some sequence.
So essentially, what we're doing
here is we're taking
this two-dimensional grid and
arranging the terms associated
with that grid, in some
particular linear order.
And we're summing those
terms in sequence.
As long as this sum converges to
something as we keep adding
more and more terms, then
this double series
will be well defined.
Notice, however, we can
add those terms in
many different orders.
And in principle, those
different orders might give us
different kinds of results.
On the other hand, as long as
the sum of the absolute values
of all the terms turns out to be
finite, then the particular
order in which we're adding the
different terms will turn
out that it doesn't matter.
There's another way that we can
add the terms together,
and this is the following.
Let us consider fixing a
particular choice of i, and
adding all of the terms that
are associated with this
particular choice of i, as j
ranges from 1 to infinity.
So what we're doing is we're
taking the summation from j
equal to 1 to infinity, while
keeping the value of i fixed.
We do this for every
possible i.
So for every possible i,
we're going to get
a particular number.
And then we take the numbers
that we obtain for the
different choices if i, so i
ranges from 1 to infinity.
And we add all those
terms together.
So this is one particular order,
one particular way of
doing the infinite summation.
Now, why start with the
summation over j's while
keeping i fixed?
There's no reason for that.
We could also carry out the
summation by fixing a
particular choice of j and
summing over all i's.
So now it is i that ranges
from 1 to infinity.
And we look at this
infinite sum.
This is the infinite
sum of those terms.
We obtain one such infinite
sum for every choice of j.
And then we take that sum that
we obtain for any particular
choice of j, and add
over the different
possible values of j.
So j goes from 1 to infinity.
This is a different way of
carrying out the summation.
And these are going to give us
the same result, and the same
result that we would also obtain
if we were to add the
terms in this particular order,
as long as the double
series is well-defined, in
the following sense.
If we have a guarantee that the
sum of the absolute values
of those numbers is finite, no
matter which way we add them,
then it turns out that we can
use any particular order to
add the terms in the series.
We're going to get
the same result.
And we can also carry out the
double summation by doing--
by adding over one
index at a time.
A word of caution--
this condition is not
always satisfied.
And in those cases, strange
things can happen.
Suppose that the sequences we're
dealing with, the aij's,
take those particular values
indicated in this picture.
And all the remaining terms, the
aij's associated with the
other dots, are all 0's.
So all these terms out
there will be 0's.
If we carry out the summation by
fixing a j and adding over
all i's, what we get here is 0,
and a 0, and a 0, and a 0.
That's because in each row we
have a 1 and a minus 1, which
cancel out and give us 0's.
So if we carry out the summation
in this manner, we
get a sum of 0's, which is 0.
But if we carry out the
summation in this order, fix
an i, and then add over all j's,
the first term that we
get here is going to be 1,
because in this column, this
is the only non-zero number.
And then in the remaining
columns, as we add the terms,
we're going to get 0's,
and 0's, and so on.
And so if we carry out the
summation in this way, we
obtain a 1.
So this is an example that shows
you that the order of
summation actually may matter.
In this example, the sum of the
absolute values of all of
the terms that are involved is
infinity, because we have
infinitely many plus or minus
1's, so this condition here is
not satisfied in this example.
Let us now consider the case
where we want to add the terms
of a double sequence, but over
a limited range of indices as
in this example, where we have
coefficients aij, which we
want to add, but only for those
i's and j's for which j
is less than or equal to i.
Graphically, this means that we
only want to consider the
pairs shown in this picture.
So these points here correspond
to i,j pairs for
which i is equal to j.
Terms on the right, or points
to the right, correspond to
i,j pairs for which i is
at least as large as j.
We can carry out this summation
in two ways.
One way is the following.
We fix a value of i, and
we consider all of the
corresponding terms, that
correspond to different
choices of j.
But we only go up to the point
where i is equal to j.
This is the largest term.
So what are we doing here?
We're taking the coefficients
aij, and we are adding over
all j's, starting from 1, which
corresponds to this term.
And j goes up to the point where
it becomes equal to i.
We do this for every
value of i.
And so we get a number for the
sum of each one of the
columns, and then we add
those numbers together.
So we're adding over all
i's, and i ranges
from 1 up to infinity.
This is one way of carrying
out the summation.
Alternatively, we could fix a
value of j, and consider doing
the summation over
all choices of i.
So this corresponds to
the sum over all
choices of i, from where?
The smallest term, the first
term, happens when i is equal
to the value of j.
And then we have larger choices
of i, numbers for
which i is bigger than the
corresponding value of j.
And so i ranges from j all
the way to infinity.
And this is the sum over one of
the rows in this diagram.
We do this for every j.
We get a result, and then
we need to add all
those results together.
So we're summing for all j's
from 1 up to infinity.
So these are two different ways
that we can evaluate this
series associated with
a double sequence.
We can either add over all j's
first and then over i's, or we
can sum over all i's first,
and then over all j's.
The two ways of approaching this
problem, this summation,
should give us the
same answer.
And this is going to be, again,
subject to the usual
qualification.
As long as the sum of the
absolute values of the terms
that we're trying to add
is less than infinity--
if this condition is true, then
the two ways of carrying
out the summation are equal, and
they're just two different
alternatives.